hello everyone and thank you for joining
me today
over the past few years there have been
much activity around implementing the
quality by design principles for
analytical method development
at waters we have also been applying
this approach for developing methods
using various software platforms
in this presentation
we will give an example of method
development application that employs the
quality by design principles
using statistical software for data
analysis and mathematical modeling
in this presentation
the focus will be on developing a method
for bodysuit thermometer and related
substances
the cost of poor quality
for pharma is is very significant and
this can cause a lot of losses including
recalls and shortages of medications
kappa overlord and loss of revenue
analytical methods play a very critical
role in the quality process and the
quality of medications
so it is critical that analytical
methods are built in a very high quality
way to to to to make robust methods
reproducible fit for purpose and very
precise
while there are many ways to develop an
ethical method
the focus of this presentation on
implementing the the analytical equality
by design for developing methods
magnetic care quality by design is a
systematic approach to method
development
that starts with the predefined
objectives
in this approach we define a region
where
a chromatographic space
where small
region of chromatographic space where
small changes will not affect the
results
this region is known as method operable
design region
we define this space by performing
design of experiments we evaluate and
sample the space efficiently as a result
we gain knowledge about method
performance characteristics and the
study factor limitations
a quality by design approach uses
statistical software to generate
experimental designs and to study
interactions of different
factors this approach is highly
comprehensive it can be automated and
offers the most knowledge about a method
and its robustness
however it requires more processing and
confirmation of final results
for this application
we will be
discussing as stated earlier symbicort
and other symbicorts
components symbicort is a medication
that is available by a prescription as
an inheritor it consists of two active
pharmaceutical ingredients medicinaid
and for material these two components
treat different symptoms of asthma
so in order to comply with regather
agencies it's important to have a method
for the analysis
of this
drug
medication
the current methods for the analysis of
bodysonide there is a usp method for the
analysis very soon i and this method
uses reverse phase hplc method
it uses a three micrometer c18 column
that is 250 millimeter
the total run time for this method is 70
minutes which make it
very
time-consuming and very
solvent-intensive method
additionally there is currently no
method no usb method that describes the
analysis of bodysuit and format role in
a single pharmaceutical formulation
so the goal of this work was to develop
a method that is ms compatible for the
analysis of bodyslide promoter and
related substances using
a fusion qbd
of as software for the analysis
another important
challenge with this application is the
fact that patisonite exists as a pair of
epimers and
resolving these two peaks from each
other is normally challenging so we
thought this would be an interesting
application to see if using a
tools would help us to make this
separation easier
all right
so with method development approach
if
that analytical equity by design
focuses on
various steps to follow when you do
method development
the first step and i think equality by
design is
setting method goals where
you start by defining the method goals
for
the the for the
for the final method
the next step is the risk assessment and
in in risk assessment we will talk we'll
talk more details about each one of
these steps in the next slide
this assessment you identify critical
method parameters that could uh
significantly affect the performance of
the goals screening where we will be
doing uh
various
we will try to
screen the effect of major
chromatographic
effectors on chromatography and
optimization is where we do
some sort of fine tuning of the final
method to make sure that we build a
robust method that can be fit for
purpose and reproducible and accurate
so if we go to the method goals the
method goes are
the analytical
objectives
that describe the intended purpose of
the method what will be measured and the
performance criteria for the
measurements
for the various knives for motorola and
related circumstances the method goals
included performance characteristics
such as
usb resolution of
at least two between all the analyze usb
tailing of four of less than 1.4 for all
the analyze percentage rsd of peak area
of less than 2 for all
peaks and percentage of
retention time of less than 1 for all
peaks
so these are the goals that we set for
this
method
the next step according to uh
or not according in that that goes in
compliance with
uh the aqbd requirements is to do risk
assessment and
in risk assessment
uh
critical method parameters are
identified and assessed for the highest
impact on the quality of the data
generated
the high risk parameters that may affect
the method's ability to meet the goals
are assessed based on the sound
chromatographic science literature
review previous knowledge and experience
criticism risk assessment is often done
by using fishbone diagram to visually
show which method parameters have the
most impact on the method performance
for pedestrianized for multiple and
related substances
the critical method parameters are
indicated in yellow
the parameters include
column chemistry mobile phase buffer
and
solvent type were identified to have the
greatest impact on the performance
therefore they were studied in the
screening phase of the method
development
other chromatographic parameters
including flow rate gradient time and
slot
injection volume can affect the
resolution between analyze these
parameters can easily be controlled
therefore they were not considered
critical design of experiment for
screening and optimization studies were
performed using fusion qbd which is a
software that is commonly used for
statistical
design of experiment method development
separate does studies were created for
screening and optimization phases doe at
each phase was exported to
the empower software for data
acquisition
after completing the runs we process
data and empower and imported results to
fusion qvd for statistical analysis
and modeling the numerical search for
best conditions was also performed
as for system we used an itchy class
system that is coupled with pda and qda
for
mass detection
and we also use a column manager that
allows us to use multi columns for
screening
this slide shows the workflow within
fusion software and we'll go over these
steps and more details in the next
slides but
in general the fusion uh
kbd method development
workflow starts with some sort of
preliminary experiments and
the reason for these experiments is too
if you don't have a a primary method
that
you can use for further screening
you can start from scratch and do some
primary experiments to find the optimum
wavelength to find the conditions where
the all of the compounds are eluted
within a reasonable time of ram
the next
step with infusion software is screening
and at this step what we do is typically
try to screen the most important
chromatographic variables the the
highest risk factors
for the performance of the method such
as the most important one is the
chemistry of columns at this stage and
mobile phases ph also is a major
influencer
in
the performance of chromatography
the next step is optimization and
optimization uh typically what is
normally done is fine tuning of the
least important chromatographic factors
to achieve the best separation between
the compounds and the most robust method
and finally
characterizing the final design space
and
creating a method operable design region
as we stated earlier where small changes
to
conditions do not significantly
change the performance of the method
so infusion
the way
uh it
treats chromatographic factors three
chromatographic factors uh as either
numerical factors or categorical factors
so numerical factors are factors with
levels which are represented by numbers
on a continuous scale which has meaning
and for which intermediate levels
between these two numbers also has a
meaning
for example if you have a temperature of
30 and temperature of 40
a temperature of 35 would have a meaning
that is a numerical factor
on the other hand
there are some factors that are
categorical where intermediates there
are where they are discontinuous and
intermediate values are not uh
particularly meaningful for example the
stationary phase chemistry if you have a
phenyl column and a c18 column there is
nothing in between the two
uh columns a major advantage for fusion
cubed is that
it minimizes the number of experiments
that are needed to obtain a a a
knowledge about a very comprehensive
knowledge about the method
so this is an example where if a full
factorial uh design of experiments
needed to be done for five temperatures
at five
different gradient times we will need 25
methods
using fusion
and doing statistical sampling this
number can be lowered to 13 which is
significant reduction number of
experiments almost 50 reduction in
number of experiments
so
fusion does statistical sampling to
reduce the number of experiments that
are required to create a
design space
now if a thin variable is added
to this study such as the ph
fusion would still apply the statistical
sampling to
uh
to create the design with minimum number
of experiments required
however
if a fourth variable that was added and
this variable is categorical
the same number of experiments will be
repeated across the different
categorical variables
with this
fusion would still say significantly
save on time by reducing the number of
experiments that
are would normally be needed if a full
factorial design
is implemented
so
for primary experiments what we did we
chose couple columns hss t3 and the
bhc18 and we just the basic goal of this
experiment is to find
appropriate wavelengths that all analyze
would uh
have decent absorption and uh no enter
much interference from the mobile phase
and also to make sure that all peaks
will elude before the end of
the run so it's a very limited number of
experiments and the purpose of this
experiment just
as stated earlier to find initially
conditions that can be used for further
screening experiments
so this is a chromatogram for initiating
experiment
note that in this chromatogram that
there are several peaks
or not
optimal
and again the purpose of this experiment
is uh just to have starting point
conditions and the peaks are not
expected to be perfect at this stage
of the study
based on the
premier screening experiment we go next
to the most
important step of this study which is
the screening
and in the screening experiment
uh uh
the goal is to
uh screen the most important factors
that could affect the separations
so
in this experiment as we are using an
itchy class system
which is a a
high performance instrument low
dispersion volume we use sub 2 micron
columns 2.1
millimeter columns and they were all 570
meters so we can achieve fast
separations
and the gradient times were between 5 to
15 minutes
online mixing from the acid and base was
uh uh
used at this stage of the study to
achieve the desired ph although this is
not
the optimum way of
preparing uh buffers but at this stage
of the study which is only to screen the
best conditions it is accepted to to use
this kind of uh online mixing uh for the
desired ph
another important thing is that the
gradient slope
in fusion can be achieved by
uh uh uh two ways either by changing uh
the the also organic solvent composition
or the gradient time fusion allows you
to do only one at a time because
uh uh it wouldn't be able to handle the
small differences uh between the uh the
two approaches
wide ranges of chemistries which is the
most important factor in a screening
experiment
was explored in this study and we'll
talk more details about these
is in the next slide
so
these are the five columns that we have
used in this study and
as as
we said earlier that for method
development the goal is to uh
choose columns that provide the widest
range of selectivity
to increase the chances of success
so we used five columns for this the
first column we used was a hc-18 which
is one of the most popular lc columns
and
it is also it it's it's available
and does have a wide range of ph range
the second column was
be a shield reverse phase
uh c18
it does offer alternative selectivity to
c18 as it contains uh embedded polar
groups that can change
uh resistivity
the third column was
a cortex t3 column which is a
superficially porous column
that gives increased attention for polar
analyze
the fourth column was
another superficial porous column which
is the cortex fennel but it does offer a
unique selectivity with thinner grooves
and pi uh pi interactions
the last column was that a
pfp column and it does have completely
different selected selectivity and it
was interesting to try this column two
uh
as
as we said earlier too to have the
widest range of selectivities
it's important to note here that
it's important to write to choose the
right geometry of columns
when
depending on the instruments you are
using and since we used an acuity
h-class system the appropriate geometry
is 2.1
millimeter columns 1.6 micrometer
particle
so for the screening experiment this
slide shows that the various
conditions that were studied in in this
screening experiment
we use categorical factors which are the
five columns and we also have used
numerical variables which are the
different ph's of 2 2.5 2.9 3.5 and 4.1
the flow rate was constant at 0.5 ml per
minute and the injector injection volume
was 3 microliters and the oven
temperature was also constant at 40
degrees celsius
the the goal here was to
keep the number of experiments uh
manageable so you get
the maximum uh
the most
reliable results out of fusion when you
cap the number of experiments to
40 or 50 experiments
an important feature in fusion method
development software is that it's highly
compatible with a wide range of
instruments waters and other windows
instruments
and it is also compatible with
various
uh
modules and various detection setups
it also automates the whole process of
exporting and creating all the methods
within empower
it also creates all the required
conditioning and equilibration steps
that are needed for the experiment
this feature is very useful
not only because it saves time
from manually entering and making all of
these methods but also it
eliminates any transcription error
it's important to note here that
although fusion interacts seamlessly
with empower it wouldn't login to
empower without
asking you for your log and credentials
it won't automatically log into empower
so it goes with the level of permission
you have for empower to log in
this slide is
a chromatogram
from the
screening experiment it showed the best
uh
looking chromatogram on each one of
these columns from the screening
experiment
and
when the experiments are done
uh you have to do the processing in
mpower and this is done normally by
browsing through the chromatograms
finding the best-looking chromatogram
and then
creating a processing method based on
that chromatogram then apply this method
to the other chromatograms
based on the results as can be seen from
the best looking chromatogram on the top
chromatogram
it was clear that there are major issues
of
these separations that need to be
addressed
the first problem first issue we had is
that the uh uh for motorola peak is very
broad peak and that that the usb
training is really high
so this needs uh to be addressed if we
want to get a
a high quality method at the end
the other important issue that
that a cluster of peaks
uh at the end are not very well resolved
so
uh uh it it
the end of these results showed us that
there is a promise but there are some
issues need to be addressed to get
a final good method
it's also important to note here that uh
using a mass detection the qed air
detector was very useful in this
exercise at as it allowed
me to know uh which week is which
at the different
chromatographic conditions it would be
much harder if you don't have mass
detector to know which peak is which
considering the different selectivities
and different illusion orders
when different chromatographic
conditions are utilized
so
the first issue wanted to address is the
formation role peak shape and to address
this issue we made an adjustment to
design of experiment this adjustment was
using high ph aqueous mobile phase
buffers
and the reason for this adjustment is
the fact that for monte roll is a base
and it will be logical that high ph
mobile phases could help improving the
peak shape of this analyte
we only used one column for this
screening which is the best column we
obtained from the previous screening
experiment the vhc-18 column
it also this column was also used
because it it it is very compatible with
a wide range of ph's including the high
ph that we are about to use in this
experiment
another important note here that
uh uh the calibration curves for the
online ph mixing that uh
were done
for a fusion software were all performed
on acuity hd class and as we are using
activity class
it means that
these
predicted
phs and the mixing uh
would be very accurate
so
as we said in the previous slide this
was done using the vfc80n column
and in this experiment
we screened a wide range of phas ranging
from 6.7 to 10.7
to see if improvements can be achieved
for the peak shape of four material
all other results were maintained the
same as in the previous experiment
including
oven temperature flow rate
and the gradient profile
so the results of this experiment showed
that for motorola pxc peak shape has
significantly improved
when high ph mobile phases you were used
for example
the tailing factor as can be seen in
this chromatogram
was less than 1.3
for uh this
less than 1.3 for this chromatogram and
for 10 other chromatograms out of the 15
experiments that were performed
for the
screening experiment
the figure
on the left of the screen image is is is
is a screen image from fusion and it
shows numerical
search for the best overall answer
and
the white area represents the
combination of experimental conditions
where the performance goals are met
and the shaded area represents the
combination of experimental conditions
where the performance goals were not net
it can be seen here that there is a wide
range of experimental conditions that
where baseline resolution can be
achieved for all analytes
so
the
results of this uh
screening experiment was successful
in addressing the picturing for motorola
and giving some promise for
a
good
separations of the cluster
of the peaks
while this method
provided good separations further
optimization
uh to reduce
uh uh hopefully to reduce the runtime or
but most importantly to
get better peak shares and better
resolutions
would be important to pursue
so the next step was optimization and
the goal of optimization is
to identify a method with optimum
performance and robustness
in this optimization we use the vhcatn
column
and we used a
variants of various uh ph buffers
we varied the list
the less important chromatographic
parameters such as flow rate and oven
temperature
and we use the three different phs and
the phs that were used in this step were
all pre-mixed
uh
buffers for more accurate results and
these buffers were uh used uh where uh
uh
employed using the switch valve on the
h-class system that allows for using
uh different solvents at the d valve
and the variables that
we used for this experiment were the
gradient time 15 to 20 minutes and the
floor 8.35 minutes and the column
temperature
it's important to note here that we used
a 10 centimeter column for the
optimization experiment
given that the five centimeter column
did not give us the desired separation
between uh challenging peaks such as the
epimotics
we thought that using a longer column
would give us higher efficiency and this
would increase the chances of success
achieving the performance goals
and just like in screening we perform
the numerical search for best method
then we explore the acceptable
performance region for that method
here we can visually examine the area of
robustness over the range of method
conditions
if we if we look at the graph
of the on the right side of the
uh slide
the x and y axis represent method
numeric variables in this case the
x-axis represents the oven temperature
and the y-axis represents the gradient
time
the box
or rectangle within the graph is
referred to
as the design space or or method
operable design region which represents
a region of an acceptable and robust
method performance
the target t at the center point
uh uh is the final method and the uh
prediction points a through d around
that box represent the confidence limits
at which
method meets the performance goals for
usb resolution peak tiering etc
you can export the prediction points to
empower software for verification runs
of your experimental conditions
overall again the unshaded area
indicates the conditions under which the
method
myth the performance goes while the
shaded area
are the conditions where the performance
goes are not net
and it's it's uh important to note here
that this is interactive display so
uh where you uh uh uh puts the precursor
the uh the on the
figure and fusion it shows you
interactive
display of the predicted chromatogram of
these conditions
another important feature uh i noticed
personally when using fusion that uh the
predictions of fusion are pretty
accurate
and this is an example of uh this table
is an example of critical pair
resolution at various uh uh
experimental conditions and the
predicted results has always been
uh very close to
the actual results and
i've done over 25 verification runs and
the predictions results have always been
within
less than
uh two percent of the uh uh
actual results for all of these 25
verification runs so it's normally
pretty accurate
so
as i said earlier you can export the
final method to m tower and do uh some
sort of verification runs for this
method
uh
and this a slide shows
multiple injections of a final method
showing that the method is robust and
the system suitability criteria i are
net the method performance goals that we
set at the beginning are all met so
usb tailing
was always
less than 1.2
uh as the final method usb resolution
was always over 2.4 for all analyze
although the goal was uh to have it over
two uh percentage rdp area have always
been for all analyzed less than one
percent
and the percentage rsv for retention
times have always been uh less than one
uh percent
for all analyzed so
the final message should to be a very
robust and uh
uh
under
under a very wide range of
chromatographic conditions
the resolution maps and fusion
enable prediction of the resolution
between the least resolved peaks
the colors
the colors represent the resolution
value between these
if if you look at the legend the red
color indicates higher resolution
an important thing to note on this uh uh
slide is that
uh the ph and the temperature have very
important effect on the separation
so
for example at a temperature of 32
degrees here you can get
a baseline separation you can get a
resolution of over two for all analyze
but
if you go to a temperature of 48 you
lose this resolution and you hardly get
you don't get any baselines resolution
for the critical pair
so
with these resolution maps they are very
informative and they would
give you information that you wouldn't
be
able to to get without this visual
representation of
these data
so in summary i hope that this
presentation uh was able to show you
that uh efficient method developments
can uh be achieved using uh
water systems and uh
fusion software uh
it allows for risk assessment it allows
for
uh defining method uh operable design
region
uh it also identifies the variables and
the critical variables that could affect
the separation of chromatography
uh
it also shows that
uh fusion can be very useful for method
development as it automates the method
development process by creating all the
desired methods for or
analyze
for all experiments
another important thing is that this
method
this work
allowed us to separate analytes that
have never been uh separated in
literature with this success
uh including the uh challenging pairs of
epimers for buddhisonite and
volusionized related
uh
compounds
uh another important thing to
note is that the qvd
development software
allows for rapid separation for all
analytes because
it uses statistical sampling to reduce
the number of experiments needed
to get a comprehensive knowledge about
the various chromatography
variables and their effect on
chromatography
and with that i would like to thank you
all for joining me today